as a new day dawns on the Atlantic coast
the Sun reveals a town that is
classically New England in almost every
way
this is a seafaring town and signs of it
are everywhere but one iconic image
stands out among the rest
it's called motif number one build in
the 1840s to house fishing gear it's
unusual name comes from a frustrated
local art teacher many of the students
would use the motif as a subject he
would see that building in their work
over and over again and the point where
one day a student brought it in and he
said Oh motif number one again the name
stuck and it's remained popular with
artists ever since artists liked it
because it was simple to paint simple to
sketch over time it became emblematic of
fishing towns all over New England yet
even this enduring symbol could not
withstand the elements forever
the infamous blizzard of 1978 blanketed
the town in almost three feet of snow
pounded the region with hurricane-force
winds and left motif number one in ruins
but New Englanders are nothing if not
resilient and resourceful they
reconstructed motif number one later
that year using some unusual ingredients
they put crankcase oil into the paint to
make it flat and so when it was painted
it actually looked worn already and to
this day they continue doing that for
the hardy New Englanders who make their
living from the sea motif number one
stands as a testament to their proud
maritime heritage so where in the world
are you you're in the town of Rockport
Massachusetts
you